das immer nicht gesagt was im video wir
machen du spielst jetzt minecraft
war bin ich immer noch gefordert
das war das minecraft hier das ist seine
welt
das hast du mir aber nicht erzählt doch
nein doch nein das war so nicht
abgesprochen ist nicht mal hallo gesagt
warum fängt ich denn jetzt an ja wir
sind mittendrin jetzt im leben also
einmal ganz kurz für dich zur erklärung
das hier ist minecraft minecraft ist ein
glöckchen spiel so ein bisschen wie lego
das hier ist eine welt in der du ja
niederrhein geboren wurdest und jetzt
musst du überleben
gar nicht orientiert sich erst mal daran
dass du mit wsd läufst
dem boden ja aber das ja auch richtig
wir wollen nicht um baum leben
muss diese umbringen rechts runter was
überhaupt für eine welt haben o
hara sieht gut aus was ist das minecraft
[Musik]
wer hat denn dann sowas spaß
in minecraft geht es darum dass man sich
sachen kräfte
nicht tot
so haben wir überlebt also du musst
jetzt erstmal holzholen deswegen jemand
zusammenbauen hin halt einfach mal die
maustaste gedrückt genau jetzt brauchst
du kannst sie heute abend dann hast du
schon dann erst zeiten sieht rechts neue
rezepte verfügbar das heißt du kannst
jetzt mit diesem holz zum aus diesem
holz neue dinge kräften wie zum beispiel
[Musik]
haus nicht ganz drückt
genau das bist du herzlich ja deshalb
passt sich man dem spieler an du kannst
jetzt ein holz unten links nehmen
das ist die erde
und jetzt kannst du das holz oben rechts
des handwerks feld packen genau und
jetzt sich zwischen rechts daneben
birkenblätter
noch mal klicken und jetzt mal raten
44 rating mit der rechten maustaste und
rechts der bank
und jetzt die banken dann inventar
ich dachte ich spiele vor neid du hast
jetzt ein schwert in der hand
was können wir mit einem shirt machen
jemand umbringen genau du gehst jetzt
erstmal daher und tötest ein paar tiere
damit wir was zu essen kriegen wirklich
ja rauchen hat weil ich glaube wenn wir
jetzt wirklich was das ist
das ist nicht mein spiel
ist kein spieler ins spiel doch ich war
gar nicht so schlecht
[Musik]
er braucht von dir gelernt das ist halt
nicht so super
duper guck mal wie du sollst dann nur
einen baum rein
ich glaube wir müssen das ganz müssen
anders angeht wir bauen das jetzt hier
erstmal ein bisschen mehr holz ab und
dann können uns mit dem holz was wir
noch weiter uns jetzt abbauen gleich
noch eine spitzhacke machen weiß was
wenn wir eine spitzhacke
rinnsteine abbauen
das war
jetzt kommen wir spielen eigentlich auch
jetzt nicht wie scheiße wieder selbst
mal die werkbank jetzt hier hin wie
mache ich das mit recht
das holz in die zur handwerk zu dingen
weil die sache ist dadurch dass wir
nehmen da steht ganz fest handwerk
drüber
du musst das holz in genau
nein
[Musik]
schwierig wenn man das spiel seit zehn
jahren oder irgendwie so spielst du
scheiße seit zehn jahren
so wie kann man denn darin gut sein was
was ist dann die aufgabe davon spaß
haben und den spaß haben bin ich gut
also ich hab keinen spaß du hast jetzt
auf jeden fall eine spitzhacke unten an
das ist ja schon wir brauchen jetzt
erstmal ganz kurz die werkbank abdi
sammelt sondern ein und dann holt sie
uns steine ich habe jetzt schon so einen
vorsprung gegeben also los geht's
und jetzt strenge wo sind den stein
ist jetzt die hülle dh du brauchst jetzt
erstmal steiner ab steine sind ja dieses
graue was überall ist von daher kann
sich da einfach linke maustaste gedrückt
halten genauer mission einsteigen
reicht eine drei steine wir
hören 200 ultras stand einfach
du musst immer die sachen kaputt die du
gerade anschaust dass sie zog dann
fahren kreuz jetzt darauf den kaputten
hier jetzt sehen dahin markus hoch
[Musik]
wie viel es wird nacht
das ist schlecht denn wir müssen uns
jetzt ein haus bauen damit wir die erste
nacht überleben können indem einfach
gibt es auch zombies
dass angst vor zahlen ist
oder warsteiner
anhört wir sehen wollt
[Musik]
nicht
warum lässt du wie ich dann immer aus ob
ich nicht doch nicht mit dir warum
läufst du den schon hier in den gleichen
baureihe wohin du nimmst dann die blöcke
beispielsweise die steiner jetzt die
mails austauscht eine bruchsteinmauer
mit welcher auszubauen wird mit rechts
richtig deswegen rechts geht's auf dem
boden
perfekte haben wir das auch du musst
natürlich dann kreist um dich rum machen
dass zuerst mal so nicht umbaus genau
hast eine blume da stehst du auf dem
stein das geht mich hier ist genau
das gesagt meine steinreichen
du brauchst ja nicht weiter rechts dass
keine steine mehr doch deren holz sehe
ich gerade das heißt du kannst
theoretisch mit den eichen holzbrettern
es auch bei der bahn da auch noch ein
und da und noch einmal quasi ein haus
hier kein dach ja sogar hoffen einfach
dass es nicht regnet
und was mache ich jetzt ist jetzt das
cabrio haus
[Musik]
ja jetzt nur halt warten bis tag ist
spielt das bändigt ja das ist das essen
vom 1 ich will allerdings sagen dass wir
die nacht jetzt hier nicht in diesem
komischen [ __ ] haus verbringen
sondern wir machen jetzt mal bist du
hast du gesagt man kann nichts machen
wir noch dass man muss schlafen nee du
kannst ja monster wird irgendwo in ein
paar monster sehen die beispielsweise
zombies gibt die hat er nicht diesen
ziemlich langsamer aber das hier nicht
direkt das ist ein hohn
also ich mag nicht mehr ja ich finde das
ganz komischer lassen vorrang hat halt
nicht bauen das halt so ein bisschen das
ding ist halt das cool an minecraft du
kannst die welt quasi komplett verändern
fordert ist es nicht
möglich
mach mal ein ding ich lass mal ein warum
kommen thema so als wärst du minecraft
let's play ich muss jetzt nur laufen und
ist
scheiße
das hat super geklappt wie hat dir
minecraft jetzt gefallen
war habe ich zwei mikros doppelte power
nicht so super ehrlich gesagt von ford
cooler